But if I recall you're like a spider-man guy
right yeah i'm gonna be in the spider-man you're
gonna be in the next spider-man right i'm gonna
be kraven i'm playing kraven the hunter in the
next spider-man movie this is where everybody's
supposed to applaud all right yeah that wouldn't
surprise me yeah you know we're having discussions
as they say we're talking about we'll see if it
happens well let me ask you about some of the
other batman then since you can't talk about
yourself we know ben affleck is also playing
batman in this movie does that mean val kilmer
george clooney if not adam if not adam west
maybe kanye west filling in there i don't know
will there be a conclave of batman's men they're
all 127 of them michael who was the best batman me
And do you still do you keep this suit at home
for like sex play or whatever or anything no
no you do not have the snow but i will i'll slip
into it now and then you know if i'm just feeling
insecure enough i just slip into the suit makes me
feel a whole lot better i'll walk around that walk
around the neighborhood a little bit you know with
things by the way things around here get a little
nervous making i just put the suit
on and poured things straightened up
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new batman video michael keaton just went
on kimmel they talked a lot about him coming back
as his batman they also talked a little bit about
him coming back and spider-man 3 as the vulture
for more sinister 6 actions so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of really big stuff coming up before the end of
the year just starting with the big stuff first
number five so michael keaton as you saw went
on kimmel last night to promote a netflix movie
that he just released called trial the chicago
seven obviously nothing to do with batman stuff
but every time he goes on kimmel going back
years and years they always talk about batman
and since he started doing the marvel mcu movies
the spider-man movies they've been talking about
that too every time he comes back on the show so
he brings up the two giant movies coming up next
year that michael keaton is supposed to be in the
flash movie as his version of batman from the tim
burton movies in spider-man 3 as the vulture i'll
talk about the batman stuff first then i'll talk
about the vulture sinister 6 spider-man 3 stuff
later in the video but if you haven't seen michael
keaton tell batman stories before especially
when he does a lot of these appearances some
of his best batman stories are about the making of
the original batman 1989 movie with jack nicholson
if you think that jack nicholson is eccentric
nowadays in his old age the stories that michael
keaton tells about them together on the set of
that batman movie 30 years ago when he was younger
are even crazier just as you would expect number
four though the first important bit of that though
is when he's prompted about coming back as batman
in the flash movie with ben affleck's batman and
he doesn't deny anything he's seemingly genuinely
excited about the prospect like it's really
exciting to come back as his version of batman
he's super happy talking about batman in general
telling batman's stories but then he throws out
the extra there are some interesting things going
on we'll see if that all happens and i think
that's him referencing all the news about the
dc and warner brothers larger plans for him beyond
the flash movie inside the dceu earlier this year
when all the trade publications variety deadline
hollywood reporter the rap the big sites reported
that he was coming back as his version of batman
from the tim burton movies they also said that he
was signing a deal for multiple movies like the
rumored henry cavill superman contract trying to
get him to come back and cross over into multiple
movies so the idea was that michael keaton's
batman would sort of take the role normally
given to ben affleck's batman in the way you saw
them put ben affleck's batman in the first
suicide squad movie then justice league and so on
like everything is connected you would expect a
version of batman to sort of cross over into other
people's movies eventually setting up another big
justice league crossover but because ben affleck
said that he's sort of transitioning away from the
batman role and the flash movie is supposed to be
his final appearance as batman the sort of leading
the intro through the flash movie for michael
keaton's batman to explain how he's now the batman
that's crossing over into the other movies without
necessarily replacing or retconing ben affleck's
batman out the other movies that everyone was
reporting that michael keaton was supposed
to be in in the future would be obviously the
flash movie first to introduce the concept of the
multiverse to the dc eu after they sort of teased
it in the flash crossover from crisis on infinite
earth's that kicks him onto the board so to speak
for the modern dc eu movies then number three
after that he's supposed to cross over into a
couple other movies as a mentor to younger heroes
i think you could consider the flash the first
person they would consider him mentoring even
though ezra miller has been the flash for a couple
years now technically in the universe he's only
had a couple adventures so he's considered one of
the younger heroes he hasn't even been given the
flash name inside the dceu cue that grant gustin
scene of him literally telling him he was supposed
to be called the flash the only other two movies
that they've suggested michael keaton's batman
would cross over into at least right now would be
a live-action batman beyond style movie and then
whatever the next justice league movie winds up
being he's not older than wonder woman but you can
consider all the other justice league characters
younger than him the wise old batman jedi with his
padawans if you watch zack snyder's panels that he
did for the justice league snyder cut this past
summer you've seen all the trailer footage so far
they're not doing any of the michael keaton
batman stuff during the justice league snyder cut
but they are introducing time travel in a bigger
way and possibly a teaser for the multiverse
zack snyder and patty jenkins from wonder woman
1984 both just teased that the flash would have
some new abilities quote-unquote we've never
seen before in the dc eu during the snyder cut
how do i do this without without giving too many
spoilers you're going to see something with flash
in this film i don't think that you've ever seen
before something that has to do with his abilities
because you know he's a quantum character he does
he he interacts with time and space so you might
see him do something that is timely when he talks
about quantum states i think that's one a dead
giveaway for the flash time traveling some more
and two teasing the multiverse a little helping
to set up the twist of the flash flashpoint movie
number two there have been a lot of rumors about
how dc's gonna handle the live-action batman
beyond movie that people have been talking about
some people think that it's going to be the
batgirl movie that they've been trying to make for
a couple years and they'll just make that movie
with a dynamic that's similar to the dynamic from
batman beyond like older michael keaton batman
mentoring barbara gordon as batgirl but in that
scenario the movie would still be titled and sold
as a batgirl movie then separately there's all the
talk about them doing a legit batman beyond movie
with a version of terry mcginnis and in both cases
it sounds like that would wind up taking place on
his earth 89 or whichever earth you want to say
he's from the earth from the tim burton batman
movies that would help explain the timeline a
little bit so his version of barbara gordon could
be old enough to become batgirl and terry mcginnis
could have aged into his early 20s the timeline
is going to be a little bit weird no matter what
between the michael keaton stuff that's going on
separately from all the dceu traditional movies
but the flash movie is going to clarify how all
that's going to work and what the dynamic is going
to be like when he's interacting with the other
justice league characters i think when michael
keaton says there's interesting stuff going on
behind the scenes hopefully everything works out
it's just a question of exactly what it's going to
look like once it winds up on screen and speaking
of other versions of batman they joke about val
kilmer batman during that george clooney adam
west batman how many other batman versions are
going to be in this new flash movie and michael
keaton jokes all of them if you remember the dc
fandom panels technically he's not joking during
the flash movie trailer in the panel that they did
at dc fandom andy muschietti the director of the
movie said that they had plans to reference pretty
much all the other dc movies from the past in some
way when they were talking about how they were
canonizing the multiverse to the dc eu they played
this footage and this montage of all the biggest
dc movies of the past like the christopher reeve
superman movies yes val kilmer batman yes classic
wonder woman linda carter series everything
this was his quote about it this movie is a bit of
a hinge in the sense that it presents a story that
implies a unified universe where all the cinematic
iterations that we've seen before are valid
what that actually means is they'll probably
have their own version of the crisis on
infinite earth's ending scene where they have a
montage of clips connecting the different series
and movies from different universes like the green
lantern movie footage was happening on earth 12
but the arrow verse is earth prime but moving into
the spider-man sinister six stuff they talk about
during this number one even though obviously
this is mostly batman video yes they do bring
up vulture coming back in spider-man 3 for more
sinister 6 setup in the mcu as we've all been
expecting michael keaton's vulture is also having
a cameo scene in the morbius movie that's supposed
to come out in march still they haven't delayed
that movie again yet so hopefully we'll find out
about that pretty soon that's meant to connect the
venom movie and those spin-offs to the tom holland
spider-man character so that it all makes sense
when spider-man and venom eventually cross over
but also while that's happening slowly start
setting up a sinister six movie between the
sony and marvel movies so really those are
like two different concepts mcu sinister six
and then spider-man and venom together but they're
filming spider-man 3 right now doctor strange 2 is
also getting ready to film and doctor strange is
going to be one of the major avengers crossover
characters in spider-man 3 so there's gonna be a
ton of spider-man news for the rest of the year
the flash movie isn't supposed to start filming
till next year which is why michael keaton says
his contract stuff isn't totally done yet they're
also trying to work around his schedule with all
the spider-man movie stuff too michael keaton is
a busy man right now and to make as many batman
puns as possible while i was finishing this video
they just announced that jared leto's joker is
coming back in the justice league snyder cut so
that'll be my next video that should post later
tonight so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that video everyone
click here to watch the flash movie trailer
again and click here for my new spider-man 3
doctor strange multiverse video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!